joining us right here from NBC sports
and football morning in America his
must-read column as it will definitely
be on Monday right after the first round
of the draft from Oregon our friends at
NBC Sports Peter King how are you Peter
okay oh you know what it was it was
delightful from my right corner desk
position sitting in front of the laptop
and just having one celebrity slash
football player slash fan of the game
after another come in and raise as much
money for nfl.com slash relief as we
possibly can almost four million last
night Peter amazing was amazing Wow uh
Turley fantastic good for you you know
yeah I'm so glad to hear that people
cared about yesterday for more reasons
other than football well I mean and
again just the the the people from all
over the pop culture landscape that
joined and gave some time the first 45
minutes everyone should go check it out
on nfl.com or at NFL Twitter handle you
can watch all if you've got three hours
of 5 hours you want to kill I mean it's
all sitting right there from last night
Peter it was amazing you know from Kevin
Hart busting the stones of Russell
Wilson and Tom Brady and you know give
him Brady grief for calling it tompa bay
because he's so you know egotistical we
was laugh out loud hilarious Strahan and
Dion and and then you know one after
another it was really great Peter so I
appreciate you asking let's get let's
get into the order of business here did
the Packers call Aaron Rodgers do they
give them a heads up and if so who was
that person did they connect last night
I I don't know what they did or not it
sounds like they didn't really uh I
forget where I forget where I read it I
read somewhere that they didn't call
them but I don't know that so I can't
say right either way man I don't know I
thought Aaron I saw Jordan love to the
Packers in a couple of mock drafts and I
don't know rich I it's just it just
doesn't make a lot of sense to me now
they say it's I say it
doesn't make a lot of sense and on the
other on the other side of the coin I
say I congratulate people who look at
football as a continuum which is what it
should you know Brian gudykunst
certainly has got a job to look at the
Packers of 2028 not just 2020 and 2021
so III don't I don't need your gate this
but the reason that I think this a
little bit different then the Favre
thing is that you know Mike McCarthy Ted
Thompson you know basically what was
happening in Green Bay I mean and not
not McCarthy yet okay but Ted Thompson
certainly in the Packers they were
wondering how much longer brett farr was
going to play he didn't want to come to
mini camp anymore a you know they just
they just didn't know how much longer
you know and and he was really starting
to think at the end of every year do I
want to keep playing so you look at that
and then he compared that to Rogers and
Rogers it seems to me he wants to play
at least 40 right
I mean he's told me that and as long as
his lit he told me as long as my legs
stay as long as I can use my legs and
all that I'm I'd like to play until I'm
40 and so you know I
this means that he probably wouldn't
play at least 40 in Green Bay because
think about how this works rich you know
he's 36 years old now and Jordan love is
got basically a five-year window in
Green Bay but in order to exercise that
fifth year don't you have to see
something in at least the first three
years of courses that I exercise the 50
year option after the third year the
difference to Peter is between this and
Favre
is the last time that Rogers had a
first-round selection used by the
Packers for his side of the ball Rogers
was a 20 year old it was in his 20s and
and and at least you know with Favre
Rogers dropped into their lap they they
trade it up to go get him
and they traded up to go get him from
one slot above where the Niners
eventually traded up to get the receiver
for their quarterback to make sure were
six minutes that they were shy of
winning it all could be bridged in the
same way that Green Bay was a game shy
of it I'm gonna give you my one other
thing that you know look I have not
talked to Aaron Rodgers I don't in the
offseason I don't have the kind of
relationship with them that I call him
anyway but but to some wonder what his
attitude must be today all you have to
do is look at the draft record of the
Green Bay Packers in the last five years
okay 15 16 17 18 19 okay
the Green Bay Packers took one receiver
in the top 130 picks of any of those
drafts and that was Ty Montgomery with
the 94th pick in 2015 he was a receiver
for one year and then they moved him to
running back so I don't count that as a
receiver sorry I mean you know so
essentially for the last five years
since Aaron Rodgers was 30 or 31 years
old they have not taken a really good
college wide receiver in the draft you
know they basically they but they were
like Bill Belichick in New England last
year okay Tom you and you and Josh you
go figure it out
you you you know you do it all the time
so here's Edelman and here's a bunch of
guys who we got off the scrapheap you
figure it out and you take us deep into
January because you always do well
there's a bridge too far and in my
opinion if you're Aaron Rodgers last
night you see that this is the best crop
of receivers maybe ever and you look and
say man we're going to get one or two of
these guys and instead
you get the guy who's going to take his
place in a couple of years so that's why
if you're Aaron Rodgers you got to be
steaming today especially since again
the team that he couldn't get past last
year was the one that was aggressive to
go up and get Brandon Hayek and and and
the Packers were aggressive to go get
his successor that said it is deep
enough where you can get I mean Daniel
Jeremiah said you can get some some
quality receiving starters could get a
very good we do need to wait for the
entire draft to be complete before we
can hit on that subject and of course
again if Jordan love is the next Rodgers
then then we can revisit this issue on
that front later on I mean Peter King
here on the Rich Eisen show one thing to
point out is that Jordan love was
available for the Patriots and they went
in a different direction they traded out
so the charges could trade up and take
Kenneth Murray the Patriots now have
somebody at the top of the second round
I mean we could keep guessing as to what
Bela checks thoughts are but he
certainly must have done the evaluation
to love and thought that's not the guy
maybe it is just gonna be Stidham when
it's all said and done Peter could be
you know could be or you know if you
look at the Patriots right now and you
look at you know they basically starting
at number 37 they've got like five of
the next 60 picks and so they could do a
lot of different things they could move
around if they wanted to if they feel
like there's a quarterback they want
they could probably you know trade down
a little bit to the middle of the second
round and take Jalen Hurd's or they
could take commit the Notre Dame tight
end that is that there's a lot of
connections a lot of people connecting
the dots there to say that the Patriots
like commit and they could get their
long-term tight end and then maybe they
trade up and who knows look I eat we're
all just throwing darts and guessing but
and it's also not out of the realm of
possibility to that they sign an
existing guy or trade a lower pick for
Andy doll so
we'll see after this weekend Peter King
here on the Rich Eisen show so based on
your reporting and your conversations
was it one big huge smoke screen from
the very beginning to the end for the
Dolphins and tool or was there truly an
evaluation that just came up with what
we assumed was going to be the result
anyway well I don't know that yet I'm
trying to endeavoring to talk to Chris
Greer sometime in the next couple of
days fine try to find out exactly what
happened and their range of thinking
here I think it's a little bit I think
it's it's it's easy now to say they
settled on this guy a long way and that
just kept a good secret could be I kind
of wonder really about and I wondered
this last night you know he I found it
amazing that neither Miami nor the LA
Chargers moved up to number three just
to prevent someone else from taking
their guy and all I can think of all I
can think of is that Miami must have
thought that look at the Chargers they
have a history of never trading they
hardly ever trade and then of course
they did later in the round so they have
a history that they're not they're not
going to move up and so and no one else
was gonna move up and Detroit was so
desperate to move down that the Dolphins
I think rich just figured nobody is
gonna go up there so let's save the
second round pick it would cost us to
move up there and let's just sit right
where we are we'll take two of their I
think that's what happened but I can't
tell you for sure yet and then I'm just
fascinated by the pick of Isiah Simmons
in Arizona I mean yeah could you Amin if
you told Cardinals fans you're gonna get
DeAndre Hopkins on offense and I believe
that's it right just rip that knob off
it's unbelievable just
when I was doing my mock draft last week
last Thursday Friday Saturday Sunday
talking to people all around the league
somebody who I trust implicitly said to
me okay I was going through my what I
saw was likely and and he said you have
isaiah simmons there at 8 i said yes and
he said give steve time isaiah simmons
because steve time you know unless
there's a desperate need steve craft
came among all of us in the league is a
take the best player and so you know
it's clear that if everybody in this
draft was just saying who's the best
player that you know simmons would be
probably second or third or fourth on
virtually everybody's list but people
say they're going to take the best
player you know but they don't always do
that obviously and in this case you know
it was clear to me that if isaiah
simmons got there that arizona had this
intense interest in him just because
they know now that they had one of these
guys before rich and his name was Tyrann
Mathieu mmm-hmm and Isaiah Simmons if
anything is more versatile and maybe
just a little bit bigger too so this is
a guy who Arizona has seen before and
love and and to me I think he's a
natural fit with the Cardinals and the
Broncos getting Jerry Judi and the
Cowboys CD lamb again if you asked John
Elway and Jerry Jones respectively
before the draft that that would be
possible and without them having to move
they don't move I guess the amazing
thing roots how about how about the
Denver Broncos do in fact finding before
the draft on moving up because they
wanted to make sure that they got one of
these I heard it was either due to your
CD land that they wanted one of those
two guys and they had they had to come
out of this draft with one of them and
they couldn't do it they couldn't make a
deal that they felt was satisfactory to
them so they sat there imagine John
Elway looking up to the heavens and just
saying thank you Lord you gave I only
wanted one and he gave me both
and I have my choice so that was a good
day for her the Broncos and just rich to
me look at the Broncos right now on
offense look at a under 25 quarterback
in under 25 running back who's had two
straight thousand yard seasons
you got Courtland Sutton now and Jerry
Judy you got no offense I mean I
honestly I don't mean to be corny I'm
really really excited about watching
Denver's offense it's you yeah and then
you throw a Melvin Gordon in because I
was through your friends yeah Alvin
Gorga you shouldn't do obviously
right I mean that's and then did the
Cowboys with CD lamb now I mean that was
tremendous he's got to be happy about
that
it was that was you know to me I
understand it was a great thing for them
and all that I get it man the Cowboys
are gonna have to win an awful lot of
high-scoring games I you know they've
got some needs on that defense
particularly in the back end and man dak
Prescott better thrilled for fifty five
hundred yards
Peter appreciate the time I know you've
got your chat with Joe burrow which you
know I'd let everybody know is a
fantastic Hall of Fame flex by you I
really appreciate that
[Laughter]
before you before you go the question is
the question is is the Chris Brown wants
to know is did they send them all let
them ask this for us did they send them
all 32 hats in the NFL or do they just
send in the by going to ask them that
question there you go that's a great
question why would they but who knows
maybe they did because they're the
pencils and you got it you got it you
got to be careful take care yourself
Peter thanks to the time it's Peter King
his Monday morning column football
morning in America that's seen on NBC
Sports and will read on NBC Sports
profile Paul talk calm I mean will be
just a must-have and you we basically
you heard he's he's just he's getting
all this together
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here